This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 1956, General Motors hosted a car expo called Motorama. As with all car expos, Motorama was a chance to show off concept cars and other kinds of long shot projects that they hoped would revolutionize the auto industry. One of the most forward-looking things on display was in a car, but a movie. That's forward-looking producer Sam Greenspan. The film was called Key to the Future. In it, we see a family of four cruising along a desert highway in a beautiful futuristic GM Firebird.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。1956年，通用汽车举办了一场名为“汽车巡展”（Motorama）的车展。同所有车展一样，Motorama 是展示概念车及其他长远项目的大好机会，他们希望这些项目能彻底革新汽车行业。当时展出的最具前瞻性的东西并非一辆汽车，而是一部电影。那是具有前瞻性的制作人萨姆·格林斯潘。这部电影名叫《通往未来的钥匙》。在片中，我们看到一家四口驾驶着一辆漂亮的未来派通用 Firebird 汽车在沙漠高速公路上驰骋。
It's got aerodynamic fins, gas turbine engines, and all glass passenger cabin. It looks like a car from the Jetsons. Only it's not flying. It's driving on a highway. But this car is actually just the set dressing for what GM really wants to show us. Their vision for a self-driving vehicle, you're now under automatic control. Hands off steering.
它拥有空气动力学尾翼、燃气轮机和全玻璃乘客舱。它看起来就像《杰森一家》里的汽车。只是它没有在飞，而是在高速公路上行驶。但实际上，这辆汽车只是通用汽车真正想向我们展示的东西的布景装饰。他们对自动驾驶汽车的愿景是：你现在处于自动控制状态。双手离开方向盘。
After being put on automatic control, the dad who's driving the car pushes the steering wheel out of the way. Oh, this is the life. Say, cool, comfortable. Mind if I spoke a cigar? No longer tethered to the steering wheel, Dad uses both hands to light his cigar. The car zooms along unimpeded. For nearly as long as there's been an auto industry, there have been dreams of a car that
进入自动控制状态后，正在开车的父亲把方向盘推到了一边。哦，这才是生活。你看，又酷又舒服。介意我抽支雪茄吗？不再受方向盘束缚的父亲用双手点燃了他的雪茄。汽车畅通无阻地向前疾驰。几乎只要汽车工业存在的一天起，就有人梦想着能有一辆
drives on its own. A car where people can enjoy all the freedom that cars offer, but without the anoints or the dangers of driving oneself. I can't speak to what specifically inspired GM to dream up the self-driving car we see in this film, but it's very possible that it had to do with safety. The film is only nine minutes long, but they can't stop commenting on how darn safe this automatic driving is. The safe, easy way to make a turn. The year that this film was shown at Motorola, 1956, that year alone, there were nearly 38,000 vehicle-related deaths in the United States. Ever since the 1950s, there has never been a year
自动驾驶的汽车。一辆能让人享受汽车带来的所有自由，却没有亲自驾车的烦恼或危险的汽车。我无法说明具体是什么激发了通用汽车构思出我们在片中看到的这辆自动驾驶汽车，但很有可能与安全有关。这部电影只有九分钟长，但他们却赞不绝口地谈论这种自动驾驶到底有多安全。安全、轻松的转弯方式。这部电影在 Motorama 车展上放映的那一年，即1956年，仅在美国就有近38,000人死于交通事故。自20世纪50年代以来，还从未有过哪一年的
with fewer than 30,000 people killed in car accidents. Vehicle-related accidents are the number one cause of death in the United States for people between the ages of 5 and 34. And more than 90% of all automobile accidents are attributable to one thing, human error. So for some industry people, a fully automated car is a kind of holy grail. The thing about automation though, is that as it solves problems, it inevitably creates new ones. As automation makes our lives easier and safer, it also creates more complex systems and fewer humans who understand those systems, which means, when problems do arise, people
车祸死亡人数少于30,000人。在美国，交通事故是5至34岁人群的第一大死因。而且超过90%的汽车事故都归咎于一件事：人为错误。因此，对于业内的一些人来说，完全自动化的汽车就像是一种圣杯。然而，自动化的问题在于，它在解决问题的同时，不可避免地会创造出新的问题。随着自动化让我们的生活变得更加轻松和安全，它也创造了更复杂的系统，而理解这些系统的懂行人却越来越少，这意味着当问题确实出现时，人们
can be left ill-equipped to deal with them. Human factors engineers call this the automation paradox. Last week in our story about automation and aviation, we heard about various ways people are trying to deal with the paradox in that industry. For one, pilots are being encouraged to practice manually flying their planes to keep their skills polished. And engineers are also trying to make smarter, more collaborative automation that doesn't strip skills from pilots, but instead works with them to complete tasks. The position I would adopt is one that has been termed a human-centered automation, where we see what you need to do and make the automation a team player.
可能会束手无策。人机工程学专家将此称为“自动化悖论”。上周在我们关于自动化与航空的故事中，我们听到了人们试图在航空业应对这一悖论的各种方法。一方面，飞行员被鼓励练习手动驾驶飞机，以保持他们的熟练技能。工程师们也在努力开发更智能、更具协作性的自动化系统，它不会剥夺飞行员的技能，而是与他们合作完成任务。我所持的立场被称为“以人为本的自动化”，即我们明确你需要做什么，并让自动化成为一个团队合作者。
That's Nadine Sartre, a human-factor's engineer who believes human pilots still have a crucial role to play in flight. I don't think the answer to it is to say, let's just get rid of the human and let's fully automate the vehicle. You know, I do feel comforted by the fact it's a pilot up there. And that is Chris Irmson. I'm Chris Irmson. I lead the self-driving car project here at Google. Chris may be glad that there are pilots and planes, but he's got a very different vision for cars.
那是纳丁·萨尔特，一位人机工程学专家，她认为人类飞行员在飞行中仍然扮演着至关重要的角色。我不认为解决这个问题的办法是说，让我们干脆摆脱人类，实现汽车的完全自动化。你知道，一想到上面有个飞行员，我确实感到心安。那是克里斯·厄姆森。我是克里斯·厄姆森。我负责领导谷歌的自动驾驶汽车项目。克里斯可能会为有飞行员和飞机而高兴，但他对汽车有着截然不同的愿景。
He believes the way to solve the automation paradox for cars is to take humans out of the operation entirely. If you have a steering wheel there, there's kind of an implicit expectation that you're going to do something with it. Where Nadine Sartre thinks that allowing for human intervention is best. Yes, you still think need a driver who is in the vehicle and who has the opportunity at least to intervene when necessary. Chris Irmson's goal is to make a car that is safe because no human is driving it.
他认为解决汽车自动化悖论的方法是将人类彻底从操作中剥离出去。如果你在那里放一个方向盘，就会有一种含蓄的期望，即你会用它做点什么。而纳丁·萨尔特则认为，允许人类进行干预才是最好的。是的，你仍然认为需要车内有一个驾驶员，并且在必要时至少有机会进行干预。克里斯·厄姆森的目标是造一辆安全的汽车，因为没有人驾驶它。
You get to sidestep all of these kind of control confusion, kind of potential challenges by taking that out of the way. You get to remove a part of the system that you can't design. No human drivers, just human passengers. We are about to enter uncharted territory for automation. Automation has been appearing in cars almost since they hit the market. Antilock brakes, automatic transmission, power steering, cruise control, GPS, cars that can parallel park themselves,
通过将这些排除在外，你可以避开所有这些控制混乱和潜在的挑战。你可以移除系统中你无法设计的那一部分。没有人类驾驶员，只有人类乘客。我们即将进入自动化未知的领域。自从汽车问世以来，自动化就几乎一直伴随着它出现。防抱死刹车、自动变速箱、动力转向、巡航控制、GPS、能自己侧方停车的汽车……
the fully autonomous self-driving car has been a long time coming. There have been a few players developing self-driving car technologies, the most visible among them being Google. In 2009, Google began retrofitting Toyota and Lexus cars with new technologies, allowing the car to drive on its own.
全自动驾驶汽车已经酝酿了很久。有一些公司一直在开发自动驾驶汽车技术，其中最引人注目的就是谷歌。2009年，谷歌开始为丰田和雷克萨斯汽车加装新技术，使汽车能够自动驾驶。
The cars can accelerate, stop at traffic signals, make turns, merge onto freeways, and avoid pedestrian cyclists and other cars, all with little or no intervention from anyone inside the car. And then in 2014, Google started manufacturing cars of their own design, cute little two-seaters with no gas pedal, brake, or steering wheel. They're designed for the user to input a destination and just sit back and let the car do everything else. Google has videos that show blind people and children
这些汽车可以加速、在交通信号灯前停车、转弯、汇入高速公路，并避开行人和骑自行车的人以及其他车辆，所有这一切都只需车内人员很少的干预甚至无需干预。然后在2014年，谷歌开始制造他们自己设计的汽车，这是可爱的小型双座车，没有油门、刹车或方向盘。它们旨在让用户输入目的地，然后高枕无忧，让汽车完成其他所有事情。谷歌有展示盲人和儿童的视频，
sitting in what we normally think of as the driver's seat as the car scoots around a test track. Well, the intent is that you shouldn't have to have any training. You should be able to get in them, tell them where you want to go, tell them you change your mind and you want to go somewhere else and then get out. Google wouldn't show me the cars, but Chris did show them to planet money's Steve head. So you want to open it up and show me the inside?
当汽车在测试跑道上行驶时，他们坐在我们通常认为是驾驶座的位置上。嗯，我们的意图是你不应该接受任何培训。你应该能够上车，告诉他们你想去哪里，告诉他们你改变主意了想去别的地方，然后下车。谷歌不肯让我看这些车，但克里斯确实把它们展示给了“金钱星球”的史蒂夫·海德。所以你想打开它并向我展示里面吗？
Sure. So this is one of our early prototypes. Well, actually, it's our fifth generation prototype. This vehicle is one of the ones that will start to be testing on the roads in Mountain View in the next, over the summer. We talked to Steve about what it was like afterwards. When you get inside, there's no dashboard,
当然。所以这是我们早期的原型车之一。嗯，实际上，这是我们的第五代原型车。这款车将是在今年夏天开始在山景城的道路上进行测试的车型之一。事后我们与史蒂夫聊了聊当时的感受。当你坐进去时，没有仪表盘，
there's no steering column. So I'm about six feet tall, and the seat is all the way against the back window of the car, and I can stick my legs straight out in front of me because there's nothing there. Well almost nothing. What you can see in the center here, so this is a steering wheel breaking gas pedals and these are for our test drivers to use, but they're removable. California law allows autonomous cars on the roadways, but only if they can be driven by a human. But the design of this car is to have none of that, right? And so there are very, very few user controls inside.
也没有转向柱。所以我身高大约六英尺，座位一直贴着汽车的后车窗，我可以把双腿笔直地向前伸，因为里面什么都没有。好吧，几乎什么都没有。你可以在这里看到中心部分，这是一个方向盘、刹车和油门踏板，这些是供我们的测试驾驶员使用的，但它们是可以拆卸的。加州法律允许自动驾驶汽车上路，但前提是必须能由人类驾驶。但这辆车的全套设计里却没有这些，对吧？所以里面极少有用户控制元件。
There are buttons to lower the windows. There's a button to pull over to the side of the road and stop. You know, if you suddenly see a yard sale, you want to check out or a friend you want to pull over and talk to. But there's also an emergency stop button, a button that halts the car in its tracks. Kind of like on an elevator, you know how there's the big red button? Well, I really need to get out now, there's something very wrong here.
有用来降下车窗的按钮。有一个把车开到路边并停下的按钮。你知道的，如果你突然看到一个庭院旧货出售想去看看，或者想靠边和一个朋友聊聊。但它还有一个紧急停车按钮，一个能让汽车当场停下的按钮。有点像电梯里那种，你知道那个大红按钮吗？好吧，我真的得马上出去了，这里出了很大的问题。
I've never pressed the red button in elevator, but it's kind of comforting to know that's there. The cars look kind of endearing and goofy, they're small and round. Steve refers to them as bubble cars, not that they would let him ride in one. Yeah, so they didn't let me ride around in the bubble car, and in fact the bubble car hadn't hit the streets of Mountain View, but he was able to get inside one of their older models. It was a retrofitted Lexus SUV.
我从来没按过电梯里的红色按钮，但知道它在那里会让人感到有些安心。这些汽车看起来有点讨人喜欢，傻乎乎的，它们又小又圆。史蒂夫称它们为“泡泡车”，倒不是说他们会让他坐进去兜风。是的，所以他们没有让我坐在泡泡车里到处逛，事实上泡泡车当时还没有开上山景城的街道，但他得以坐进了他们较旧的车型之一。那是一辆改装过的雷克萨斯 SUV。
Okay, should I jump in the front or the back? Probably. Yeah, probably this back left corner right here. I think the most remarkable thing for me was how quickly the experience became just kind of boring. It came to a full and complete stop at the stop sign. Definitely. So the car follows the law very closely. To Steve as a passenger, the car's driving was more or less indistinguishable from a human driver. Well, a human driver that always follows the rules of the road.
好吧，我是跳到前面还是后面？大概。是的，大概就是这个左后角这里。我认为对我来说最了不起的事情是，这种体验变得多么快就变得有点无聊了。它在停车标志前彻底停了下来。确实。所以这车非常严格地遵守交通规则。对作为乘客的史蒂夫来说，这辆车的驾驶表现与人类司机几乎没有区别。好吧，是一个总是遵守交通规则的人类司机。
We were driving through a residential neighborhood in Mountain View, including through streets that were under construction. So it was navigating streetscapes that were changing. You know, lanes were blocked off, lanes were closed. And at one point on their drive, a construction worker was directing traffic, and Steve was chatting with the other person in the car. We were both sort of distracted. And suddenly, all on its own.
我们正穿过山景城的一个住宅区，其中包括一些正在施工的街道。所以它在不断变化的街景中穿行。你知道，车道被封锁了，车道被关闭了。在他们行驶途中的某个时刻，一名建筑工人在指挥交通，史蒂夫正在和车里的另一个人聊天。我们俩都有点走神了。突然间，它完全靠自己。
Temporary stop sign. Wow. The car slammed on the brakes. It was startling. So that was startling. So, that was quite interesting. Steve and the Google employees hadn't seen it, but the construction worker had flipped his handheld sign
临时停车标志。哇。汽车猛踩刹车。这太让人吃惊了。所以这很吃惊。所以，这相当有趣。史蒂夫和谷歌的员工没有看到它，但建筑工人已经把手持标志
from slow to stop. The machine had noticed that handheld stop sign when all of us had missed it, and it actually kind of scared all of us because we didn't see it. Even the Google employees hadn't seen that before. The autonomous car was working better than they had expected. Maybe these things can react faster than humans, but sensors will fail, navigation will
从“慢”翻转到了“停”。在我们所有人都没注意到的时候，机器注意到了那个手持停车标志，它实际上把我们所有人都吓了一跳，因为我们没有看到它。甚至连谷歌的员工以前也没有见过这种情况。这辆自动驾驶汽车的运行情况比他们预期的还要好。也许这些东西的反应速度比人类快，但传感器会失灵，导航会
get screwy, onboard computers will break. Car owners barely know how to fix their own vehicles as it is now, so will people be able to fix the kinds of complicated problems that come with a self-driving car? It really depends on how they end up being used in the market, right? Chris imagines that if a self-driving car breaks while it's on the road, it'll pull over. And another car will come fetch the passengers, leaving the broken one for technicians to fix. Which means, Google doesn't want to just change how we relate to our cars.
变得一团糟，车载电脑会坏掉。目前车主们甚至都不知道怎么修理自己的车辆，那么人们能修复自动驾驶汽车带来的那种复杂问题吗？这确实取决于它们最终在市场上如何被使用，对吧？克里斯设想，如果一辆自动驾驶汽车在路上抛锚了，它会靠边停车。然后另一辆车会来接走乘客，把坏掉的车留给技术人员修理。这意味着，谷歌不仅想改变我们与汽车的关系。
Google wants to change how cars relate to society. If you look at the car that you own today, it's kind of sat parked somewhere 95% of the time, and that's kind of poorly using both your financial resources that went into it, but also the environmental resources, the material and energy we put into making that vehicle. So if we can use that more efficiently by sharing it, that sounds fantastic. Maybe, eventually, instead of owning these cars, you would hail them from off the street. And when you get out, the car would drive off and pick up someone else. In other words, it's possible that these cars could enable a world in which no one owns a car,
谷歌还想改变汽车与社会的关系. 如果你看一下你今天拥有的汽车，它有大约 95% 的时间都停在某个地方，这既是对投入其中的财务资源的糟糕利用，也是对环境资源、我们制造该车辆所投入的材料和能源的糟糕利用。因此，如果我们能通过共享来更有效地利用它，这听起来太棒了。也许最终，你不用拥有这些汽车，而是可以在街上随叫随到。当你下车时，车会开走并去接另一个人。换句话说，这些汽车有可能创造这样一个世界：没有人拥有汽车，
and all of us just get around by robot taxi. Well, so the great thing about predicting the future is that you're always strong. My name is Costa Samaris. I'm an assistant professor in the Civil and Environmental Engineering Department at Carnegie Mellon University. Costa Samaris has thought a lot about how self-driving cars will change society. He is the co-author of a report called Autonomous Vehicle Technology, a guide for policymakers. So Costa, like Chris Hermson, and pretty much everyone else I met working on autonomous vehicles, he thinks that these things hold a lot of promise.
我们所有人出行都靠机器人出租车。好吧，预测未来最棒的事情在于你总是对的。我叫科斯塔·萨马里斯。我是卡耐基梅隆大学土木与环境工程系的助理教授。科斯塔·萨马里斯对自动驾驶汽车将如何改变社会进行了深入思考。他是一份名为《自动驾驶汽车技术：决策者指南》的报告的合著者。所以科斯塔和克里斯·厄姆森一样，以及我遇到的大多数致力于自动驾驶汽车的人一样，他认为这些东西大有可为。
So reducing crashes is the first way that automation will help society. But that's really only the starting point. After all, the vast majority of American cities are built around cars. And so, transforming the car means transforming the city, starting with parking lots. Because if all or most cars are taxis, we don't need to clear out spaces and congested downtowns just so cars can have a place to sit idle. Get out of the robot taxi and it's off to give a ride to
因此，减少撞车事故是自动化帮助社会的第一种方式。但这其实只是个起点。毕竟，绝大多数美国城市都是围绕汽车建造的。因此，改造汽车意味着改造城市，从停车场开始。因为如果所有或大部分汽车都是出租车，我们就不需要为了让汽车有地方闲置而清理拥挤市中心的宝贵空间。从机器人出租车下来，它就出发去载
someone else. Urban cores get denser, downtowns get more walkable, and the roads that we do have can be used more efficiently. All the things we learned in drivers at, staying a certain amount of seconds behind a speeding car, those things will now be taken over by self-driving vehicles and they will make the determination of how far it's to be from the car in front of us and in order for everybody to be safe. This would allow cars to get closer together and not just bumper to bumper, side to side. The Department of Transportation requires that highway lanes be at least 12 feet wide. That's about twice as wide as the average car.
其他人了。城市核心区变得更稠密，市中心变得更适合步行，我们现有的道路也能得到更高效的利用。我们在驾校学到的所有东西，比如与超速汽车保持一定的秒数距离，这些事情现在将由自动驾驶汽车接管，它们将决定与前方汽车保持多远距离，以确保每个人的安全。这将使汽车能够靠得更近，不仅是前后保险杠贴紧，侧面也是如此。交通部要求高速公路车道宽度至少为12英尺。这大约是普通汽车宽度的两倍。
So suddenly, a three-lane highway can accommodate six lanes without any new construction. Less space between cars means more cars can get where they're going faster. But these cars could also reorganize cities for the worse. Right now I have a cost of driving, and that cost is running my vehicle, and also the time that I'm in it. And if one could read or sleep or write emails in a robot car, people might feel just fine about living far outside the city
所以突然之间，一条三车道的高速公路无需任何新建工程就能容纳六条车道。车与车之间间距更小，意味着更多的车能更快到达目的地。但这些汽车也可能以糟糕的方式重塑城市。目前我有一项驾驶成本，这个成本就是运营我的车辆，还有我在车里花费的时间。如果有人可以在机器人汽车里读书、睡觉或写电子邮件，人们可能会觉得住在远离城市的地方
and commuting a long way in. And that type of scenario, we would see lots more vehicle miles traveled, lots more sprawl into the deep excerpts and into the country. And of course, the inside of the car could become another place for advertising. Your route data could be for sale.
并长途通勤感觉完全可以接受。在这种情况下，我们会看到车辆行驶里程大幅增加，向远郊和乡村的蔓延也会大幅加剧。当然，汽车内部也可能成为另一个广告投放场所。你的路线数据可能会被出售。
Maybe it knows I hadn't had coffee because it's connected to my refrigerator and my coffee maker at home and it says, he hasn't had coffee yet, let's make the slow route next to the coffee place. Or the route data could even become a matter of national security. Bad actors can take control of your car or a fleet of cars and stop every car that's on the bay bridge at one time for malicious intent. Clearly there are still a lot of details to work out. But I wonder, once the science is done and the policy is carefully considered, will people
也许它知道我还没喝咖啡，因为它连接了我家的冰箱和咖啡机，它说，他还没喝咖啡呢，让我们走咖啡店旁边那条慢路线吧。或者路线数据甚至可能成为国家安全问题。不法分子可以控制你的车或车队，出于恶意目的同时拦下海湾大桥上的每一辆车。显然，还有很多细节需要敲定。但我很好奇，一旦科学研究完成，政策经过深思熟虑，人们
even want these things? Is America ready to give up the steering wheel? I mean, will people still go on road trips and tailgate in the stadium parking lot? Will people even want these things? Is America ready to give up the steering wheel? I mean, will people still go on road trips and tailgate in the stadium parking lot? Will you still be able to get in your car and go on an aimless contemplative drive? I guess we haven't really thought about that.
还会想要这些东西吗？美国准备好放弃方向盘了吗？我是说，人们还会去公路旅行，在体育场停车场举行汽车尾随派对吗？人们还会想要这些东西吗？美国准备好放弃方向盘了吗？我是说，人们还会去公路旅行，在体育场停车场举行汽车尾随派对吗？你还能坐上车去漫无目的地沉思驾驶吗？我想我们真的还没考虑过这个问题。
That's Chris Irmson from Google again. My assumption is you would give it a destination and say where you wanna go, but you'll always be able to change it, right? So I don't do a whole lot of contemplative driving, but when I do, you know, you start heading somewhere and then you're like, oh, maybe I'll go this way afterwards. But you know, sometimes you really just need to get in your car and go. Like say, if you're getting chased by gun-toting corporate goons trying to stop you from aiding
那是谷歌的克里斯·厄姆森再次发言。我的假设是，你会给它一个目的地，说明你想去哪里，但你总是可以改变它，对吧？所以我不怎么进行沉思驾驶，但当我有需要时，你知道的，你开始朝某个地方开去，然后你会想，哦，也许之后我会走这条路。但你知道的，有时你真的只需要上车就走。比如，如果有持枪的公司打手追杀你，试图阻止你协助
Martian colonist rebels, you know, like Arnold Schwarzenegger did, in total recall. Hello! I'm Johnny Cat. Where can I take you tonight? violinist rebels, you know, like Arnold Schwarzenegger did, in total recall. At which point Arnold rips the robot driver out of the car and pilots it himself. It's funny because as fantastical as the sci-fi world is, we can recognize the same kinds of user annoyances we have here in the present. And we can see Arnold as heroic because he can do the things the machines can't. And think about Star Wars, when Luke Skywalker is on his way to blow up the Death Star. For one, his robot co-pilot gets fried.
火星殖民地叛军，你知道的，就像阿诺德·施瓦辛格在《全面回忆》里做的那样。你好！我是强尼·卡特。今晚我能带你去哪里？，你知道的，就像阿诺德·施瓦辛格在《全面回忆》里做的那样。此时阿诺德将机器人司机从车里扯出来，自己亲自驾驶。这很有趣，因为尽管科幻世界光怪陆离，我们却能认出现今社会中同样存在的那些用户烦恼。我们能把阿诺德视为英雄，因为他能做到机器做不到的事。想想《星球大战》，当卢克·天行者去炸毁死星的路上时。一方面，他的机器人副驾驶被打坏了。
And he turns off his onboard automation. Because automation is not as good as what Luke can do on his own. As much as we love building things that make our lives easier, it seems like we never get tired of seeing someone cast the robots aside. We love seeing people do things by hand. It's like we all have this anxiety about if we lose the ability to do something ourselves, are we losing a piece of ourselves or something? We are going to have to answer these existential questions about our cars kind of soon.
然后他关闭了车载自动化系统。因为自动化不如卢克自己做的好。尽管我们喜欢制造让生活更轻松的东西，但我们似乎永远不会对看到有人将机器人抛在一边感到厌倦。我们喜欢看人们亲自动手做事。这就像我们所有人都有这样一种焦虑：如果我们失去了自己做某事的能力，我们是否正在失去自我的一部分或其他什么？我们很快就不得不回答关于我们汽车的这些存在主义问题。
Chris Erbsen has said that his personal goal is to get the Google self-driving car done by 2020. So that his two sons, the oldest of whom is 11, will never need to get a driver's license. I would definitely think that when his son reaches 16 or 17, you would have to get a driver's license. Raj Raj Kumar is friends with Chris. They used to work together at Carnegie Mellon University before Chris went over to Google. Raj is co-director of CMU's Autonomous Driving Collaborative Research Lab. The university has been working on automated cars since the 1980s. About six months back, we literally celebrated the 30th birthday of actually working on
克里斯·厄姆森曾表示，他的个人目标是在2020年之前造出谷歌自动驾驶汽车。这样他的两个儿子（其中大儿子11岁）就永远不需要考驾照了。我绝对认为当他的儿子长到16或17岁时，你必须去考个驾照。拉杰·拉杰库马尔是克里斯的朋友。在克里斯去谷歌之前，他们曾在卡耐基梅隆大学共事。拉杰是卡耐基梅隆大学自动驾驶协同研究实验室的联合主任。该大学自20世纪80年代以来一直在研究自动驾驶汽车。大约六个月前，我们刚刚庆祝了实际从事
self-driving vehicles. Raj is also the CEO of a company called Automatica, which has a prototype vehicle that has already driven itself from San Francisco to New York, but Raj doesn't plan on taking the steering wheel out just yet. In fact, his car actually monitors the person in the driver's seat and beeps at him or her if the driver's eyes wander from the road. Raj is not in a rush to have us 100% dependent on his autonomous technology. The way he sees it unfolding is with incremental advances over time.
自动驾驶汽车研发工作的30周年纪念。拉杰也是一家名为 Automatica 的公司的首席执行官，该公司拥有一辆原型车，已经完成了从旧金山到纽约的自动驾驶，但拉杰并不打算现在就拆掉方向盘。事实上，他的车实际上会监测驾驶座上的人，如果司机的视线从路上移开，就会对其发出蜂鸣声。拉杰并不急于让我们百分之百依赖他的自动化技术。在他看来，这一切将通过长年累月的渐进式进步来展开。
Just like right now, pretty much all cars have cruise control and some cars have adaptive cruise control, which calibrates speed. The next generation of this technology, I guess, would be you do not have to control the steering wheel either. You get onto the highway, pick a lane, and then engage this so super I guess, would be you do not have to control the steering wheel either. You get onto the highway, pick a lane and then engage this so super cruise control and then you'll likely steer itself, break itself and accelerate itself. Raj also imagines an automatic mode from when you're stuck in a traffic jam. And then the number of scenarios that are automatable will increase over time and one fine day,
就像现在一样，几乎所有的车都有巡航控制，有些车有自适应巡航控制，可以校准速度。这项技术的下一代，我想，将是你也不必控制方向盘。你上高速公路，选择一条车道，然后启动这个超级巡航控制系统，它就会自动转向、自动刹车并自动加速。拉杰还设想了一种适用于你陷入交通堵塞时的自动模式。然后可自动化的场景数量会随着时间的推移而增加，直到某一天，
the vehicle is able to control itself completely But that last step will be a relatively minor incremental step and one would barely notice that hey, this actually happened So to me it will take anywhere between 10 to 20 years So while Raj does see humans as having an important role to play as we transition toward fully automated vehicles His goal like Chris Irmsons, is to eventually get human drivers out of the process entirely. But even when that day finally comes, when we don't need steering wheels and don't even notice that they're gone, there will still be accidents.
车辆能够完全控制自身。但最后一步将是一个相对较小的渐进步骤，人们几乎不会注意到，嘿，这居然发生了。所以对我来说，这需要10到20年的时间。因此，尽管拉杰确实认为人类在向完全自动自动化汽车过渡的过程中扮演着重要角色，但他的目标和克里斯·厄姆森一样，最终是将人类司机完全从这个过程中剥离出去。但即使到了那一天，当我们不再需要方向盘甚至没有注意到它们已经消失时，仍然会发生事故。
There will always be some edge cases where things do go wrong, beyond anybody's control. This is kind of the nightmare scenario for all of us researchers. If somebody deploys something prematurely, and then it turns out that it ends up killing a child, God forbid. If and when people do get hurt in autonomous cars, there may be circumstances in which the passengers wouldn't have been injured had there been a human at the wheel. These cases will be hard to reckon with, but we'll have to keep in mind that there were 30,000 Americans dying every year in human-driven cars.
总会有一些超出任何人控制范围的边缘情况，导致事情出错。这可以说是我们所有研究人员的噩梦场景。如果有人过早地部署了某些东西，结果证明它最终杀害了一个孩子，上帝保佑。如果且当人们在自动驾驶汽车中受伤时，如果在方向盘后面有一个人类的话，可能会在某些情况下乘客本不会受伤。这些情况将很难应对，但我们必须记住，每年有30,000名美国人在人类驾驶的汽车中丧生。
If autonomous vehicles lead to fewer car accidents, then as with planes, we're going to need to accept edge cases and periodic failures as the cost of living in this safer world. But I don't wanna be an edge case. I don't want to be an edge case. I don't want to give up total control of something when being in control might save my life. And yet while I was reporting the story, I almost caused a terrible car accident. It was early, the sun was in my eyes, and I wasn't really paying attention as I had made
如果自动驾驶汽车能减少交通事故，那么就像飞机一样，我们将需要接受边缘情况和周期性故障，将其作为生活在这个更安全世界中的代价。但我不想成为边缘情况。我不想成为边缘情况。当处于控制之中可能会救我一命时，我不想放弃对某事物的绝对控制。然而，在我报道这个故事时，我差点引发了一场可怕的车祸。当时天色尚早，阳光刺眼，当我在斑马线上拐左弯时，我并没有真正集中注意力，
a left through a crosswalk. And I nearly struck a pedestrian. I got so close that the guy could have reached out and slammed his fist on the hood of my car, which he didn't do, though I wouldn't have blamed him if he had. And this terrifies me. I want automation to save me and everyone else from myself. And I want automation to protect me from everyone else. And so when the time finally comes, I will probably roll the dice on autonomous cars. I think we all will eventually.
我差点撞到一名行人。两车距离近得那家伙只要伸出手就能一拳砸在我的车前盖上，他虽然没这么做，但我若被砸也绝不怪他。这把我吓坏了。我希望自动化能把我及其他人从我自己的手中拯救出来。我也希望自动化能保护我不受其他所有人的伤害。因此，当那一刻终于到来时，我可能会在自动驾驶汽车上孤注一掷。我想我们最终都会这么做。
Maybe one day I will be an old man bouncing grandkids on my knees saying, you know, when I was a young man, we drove cars ourselves. You move them around with foot pedals and a thing called a steering wheel. And they'll say, well a steering wheel. And they'll say, well, that sounds amazing! And I'll say, eh, it was alright. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Sam Greenspan with Katie Mingle, Avery Troubleman and me Roman Mars, reporting from Sweden. Extra special thanks to Steve Han and Planet Money, the great, great Planet Money,
也许有一天，我会成为一个老头，把孙辈抱在膝盖上说，你知道的，当我年轻的时候，我们是自己开车的。你用脚踏板和一个叫方向盘的东西来操作它们。他们会说，哇，方向盘。他们会说，哇，听起来太棒了！我会说，呃，还行吧。今天的 99% Invisible 由萨姆·格林斯潘制作，合作者包括凯蒂·明格、埃弗里·特鲁布曼以及我——罗曼·马斯，在瑞典进行报道。特别感谢史蒂夫·韩和“金钱星球”、伟大的“金钱星球”，
Tristan Cook, Bob Sharet, Chris Nostle, Joe Brown, Caitlin Jabari, Jackie Miller, and Sherry Stokes. This story started life as another story about automatic doors in trains in Argentina, special thanks to the folks who helped us out there, Tomas Balmulseta, Gisermo Fiorita Catalano, Mariano Pachala, Annie Murphy, Jim Greller, Anna Adlerstein, Stephanie Foo, Ernesto Falzone and Ricardo Barriero at the Association of Trainway Friends in Argentina.
特里斯坦·库克、鲍勃·沙雷特、克里斯·诺斯特尔、乔·布朗、凯特琳·贾巴里、杰基·米勒和谢里·斯托克斯。这个故事最初是关于阿根廷火车自动门的故事，特别感谢在那里帮助过我们的朋友：托马斯·巴尔穆塞塔、吉塞莫·菲奥里塔·卡塔拉诺、马里亚诺·帕查拉、安妮·墨菲、吉姆·格雷勒、安娜·阿德尔斯坦、斯蒂芬妮·富、埃尔内斯托·法尔佐内以及阿根廷铁道之友协会的里卡多·巴里耶罗。
We are a project of the 99.7KALW San Francisco and produced under the offices of Arxan, a beautiful architecture firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook, all of us are on Twitter, we're on Instagram, Tumblr, we even have a Spotify playlist, but you can find all the information you need about this show and every other episode we've ever done at 99pi.org. ever done at 99pi.org. Radio to P.O. from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是旧金山 99.7 KALW 的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心美丽的建筑事务所 Arxan 的赞助下制作。你可以在 Facebook 上找到并关注这个节目，我们所有人都在 Twitter、Instagram、Tumblr 上，我们甚至还有一个 Spotify 播放列表，但你可以在 99pi.org 上找到关于这个节目以及我们做过的所有其他剧集你需要的所有信息。PRX电台播出。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。